we're excited to welcome you to the next
generation of sports game bringing
world-class athletes to life by
recreating their athleticism intensity
and emotion like no game has before I'm
Brian Hayes creative director on EA
sports UFC and this is your inside look
at the stars of our game the fighters we
scan the fighters from the UFC using our
most advanced capture technology these
high-resolution images allowed us to
create highly detailed models in each
athletes face and body and a level it
just wasn't possible before combined
with the incredible power of
next-generation consoles we're able to
use high resolution textures and dynamic
lighting technology to achieve a level
of realism unattainable on previous
generations this is literally as real as
it gets to make you feel the fight the
scanning process captured far more than
just physical features new facial
animation technology means we can give
each athlete a sense of awareness
intelligence and emotion inside and
outside the Octagon utilizing unique
expressions captured from the UFC
fighters themselves from warm-ups to
signature stances we've captured
hundreds of distinctive animations to
bring the UFC's biggest stars delight
making every time you step in the
Octagon to face them feel authentic in
the world of EA sports UFC Anthony
Pettis has a swagger GSP respects the
opposition Wanderlei Silva can
intimidate with a look Jon Jones and it
gets to beat John J
feel the fight for yourself when EA
sports UFC drops this spring stay tuned
for more dev Diaries featuring dynamic
striking submission battles living world
and much more